(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
Comme l'intervenant avant moi, je suis -- J'imagine une novice du TED --
C'est aussi la première fois que je suis présente ici.. je ne sais pas quoi dire.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis très heureuse d'avoir était invité par Mr Anderson.
Je suis vraiment reconnaissante d'avoir la chance de jouer pour chacun de vous.
Le morceau que je viens d'interpréter est de Józef Hofmann.
Ça s'appelle le Kaléidoscope.
Hofmann est un pianiste et compositeur de la fin du 19ème siècle.
il est reconnut comme l'un des plus grands pianistes dans le monde.
Il y'a un autre morceau que j'aimerai jouer pour vous.
C'est "Abegg Variations" de Robert Schumann,
un compositeur allemand du 19ème siècle.
Ce nom Abegg s'écrit A-B-E-G-G,
et ces lettres sont le thème principal de la mélodie.
C'est originaire du nom de famille d'une des "amies" de Schummann.
(Rires)
Mais il a écrit ce morceau pour sa femme.
Si l'on écoute avec attention,
on doit normalement entendre cinq variations dans le thème Abegg.
Çe fut écrit aux environs de 1834, donc, bien que ce soit vieux,
j'espère que vous apprécierez.
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant, c'est l'heure du moment que je déteste...
Parce que Mr Anderson m'a dit
que cette session s'appelait "Sync and Flow", je me suis demandé,
"Qu'est ce que je sais que ces génies ne savent pas?"
Donc je vais parler de composition musicale,
bien que je ne sache pas par quoi commencer.
"Comment est-ce que je compose?"
Je pense que Yamaha fait vraiment du bon travail pour nous apprendre comment composer.
Ce que je fais en premier lieu, c'est créer plusieurs petites idées musicale --
que l'on pourrait rapidement improviser au piano --
et je choisis celle qui va devenir mon thème majeur, ma mélodie principale,
tout comme Abegg que vous venez d'entendre.
Une fois que j'ai choisis mon thème principal je dois décider
parmi tous les différents styles de musique, lequel je veux pour cette mélodie?
Cette année, j'ai composé un style romantique.
Donc pour m'inspirer, j' ai écouté Liszt et Tchaikovsky
et tous les autres grands compositeurs du style romantique.
Ensuite, je crée toute la structure de ma pièce à l'aide de mes professeurs.
Ils m'aident à planifier la pièce dans son intégralité,
puis, la partie difficile est de remplir cette structure avec des idées musicales,
car il faut penser.
Quand la pièce prend une certaine forme solidiée --
solide, excusez-moi -- une forme solide,
on doit soigner la pièce, soigner les détails,
et ensuite soigner l'interprétation globale de la composition.
Et il y'a une autre chose que j'aime faire, c'est dessiner --
dessiner, parce que j'aime ça, vous savez comme ces dessins animé Japonais.
Je crois que ça fait fureur parmi les adolescents actuellement.
Et un jour, j'ai réalisé
qu'il y a un parallèle entre la création de musique et la création d'art,
car la raison de son dessin ou l'idée initiale de son dessin,
c'est son personnage -- on veut décider qui on veut dessiner,
ou si on veut dessiner un personnage d'origine.
Et ensuite on veut décider, comment allons-nous dessiner ce personnage?
Par exemple, vais-je utiliser une seule page?
Est-ce que je vais le dessiner sur ordinateur?
Est-ce que je vais utiliser une page double comme dans une bande dessiné
pour, j'imagine, un effet plus grandiose?
Ensuite on doit faire l'esquisse première du personnage,
qui s'apparente à la structure de sa pièce,
puis on ajoute du stylo, du crayon et n'importe quoi d'autre dont on a besoin --
ça c'est soigner son dessin.
Il y'a une autre chose en commun
c'est son état d'esprit, car je ne --
Je suis une de ces adolescentes qui sont facilement distraites,
donc si j'essaye de faire mes devoirs,
si j'essaye de faire mes devoirs et que je ne le sens pas,
je vais essayer de dessiner, ou vous savez, perdre mon temps.
Seulement, ce qui arrive parfois c'est que je ne peux absolument pas dessiner
ni composer du tout, et là c'est comme
si j'avais trop de choses en tête.
Comme quand on peut pas se concentrer sur ce qu'on est censé faire.
Mais parfois, si on arrive à organiser son temps avec sagesse et de s'y tenir,
on en tire quelque chose, mais ça ne vient pas naturellement.
Ce qui se passe c'est que, si quelque chose de magique arrive,
si quelque chose de naturel, d'innée t'arrive,
tu deviens capable de produire cette chose belle dans l'instant,
et c'est ce que je considère comme le flow,
car tout devient logique, linéaire et on est capable de tout.
On se sent comme au meilleur de son jeu
et tout devient possible.
Je ne vais pas jouer mes compositions personnelles aujourd'hui car,
malgré les avoir finis, c'est beaucoup trop long.
Au lieu de cela, je vais essayer quelque chose appelé l'improvisation.
J'ai ici, sept notes de musique,
une note de l'alphabet musicale par carte,
je souhaiterai que quelqu'un vienne ici pour en choisir cinq.
Un volontaire, pour venir ici et en choisir cinq?
Ensuite je vais les organiser sous forme de mélodie et faire une improvisation.
Cool un volontaire !
(Applaudissements)
Ravis de vous rencontrer.
Goldie Hawn: Merci. J'en choisis cinq?
Oui, cinq cartes. N'importe lesquelles.
GH: OK. Une. Deux. Trois.
Oh, D et F -- trop familières.
(Rires)
JL: Une de plus.
GH: OK, le E comme Effort.
JL: Pourriez vous les lire à voix haute dans l'ordre ou vous les avez choisis?
GH: OK. C, G, B, A et E.
JL: Merci beaucoup.
GH: De rien. Et celles-là?
JL: Je n'en ai pas besoin. Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Maintenant qu'elle à choisit C, G, B, A, E.
Je vais essayer de les mettre dans un certain ordre.
OK, c'est bon comme ça.
Il me faut un moment pour réfléchir,
et je vais essayer d'en faire quelque chose.
(Applaudissements)
La prochaine musique, ou plutôt le bis, que je vais vous jouer
est appelé " Bumble Boogie" de Jack Fina.
(Applaudissements)
Applaudissements)